Hey, Conan O'Brien here,
and I got some exciting news.
People say that all the time,
and then they don't have anything really to say.
But I got something good to say,
so I'm actually telling the truth.
This year we're at Comic-Con.
And, as always, we are featuring
four new Funko Pop! Figures.
This is pretty cool, check it out.
This year, Spiderman.
"I'm a reboot, hahaha."
And, just like me, it has the body of a 15-year-old boy.
Check this one out, "Star Wars", and look,
it even comes with a little "Star Wars" logo, right there.
Because, without it, I get sued.
So, we keep that baby on.
Ha ha, can't get me now.
Look at this, this is the Flash.
His power is that he's very speedy.
I don't know, I never quite bought that.
But I still love...
You gotta love the Flash.
You gotta get this one.
You really have to get this one.
And then, if you're a "Game of Thrones" fan,
check it out, White Walker.
This is basically modeled on me,
not wearing a shirt at the beach.
Ah so, these are cool.
These are available.
If you watch my show,
you will be able to get one of these.
And true story, every year,
people gobble these up,
and then they're on Ebay for thousands of dollars.
That means, within the decade,
each one will be worth millions of dollars.
That's just math.
Okay, peace out.
Tupac.
I don't know.
Comic-Con?